Okay, ich habe jetzt nicht Dresden, ich habe jetzt Frankfurt 2, nicht einfach nur Frankfurt
2.
Ich habe keinen selbstgebauten Router, außerdem war das doch ein Witz von ihm.
Ich glaube es wissen alle hier, dass es nichts bringt.
Okay, schauen wir mal, jetzt sind wir in Frankfurt 2, gucken ob das jetzt besser funktioniert.
Also wenn es jetzt nicht funktioniert, gehe ich off.
Jetzt muss ich mir Werbung in der Vorschau zu meinem eigenen Stream angucken, ganz toll.
Dankeschön Twitch, keck wait.
Gehts jetzt?
Okay, vielleicht haben wir Glück und es tut jetzt, schauen wir mal.
Na, fix, ich weiß nicht ob das fix ist, das hatten wir immer mal ein paar Phasen jetzt
dazwischen.
Also es gibt anscheinend ein Problem, wir machen jetzt einfach weiter, wir machen jetzt
einfach weiter, das hat ja keinen Sinn.
Also es gibt wohl ein Problem, wenn einer einen Jeep verwendet, US, okay, also wir brauchen
noch einen neuen Account, jetzt gehts anscheinend, wir brauchen noch einen neuen Fake Account,
jeepNA, also jeep, jeep, jeep, jeep, jeep, jeep, jeep, jeep, jeep, jeep, jeep, jeep,
neuer Fake Account, North America, USA, 10 Minute Mails, ja ich brauch ne andere E-Mail
Adresse, die da, die brauch ich jetzt unbedingt, E-Mail, nee, Register, mal gucken ob wir die
Probleme von ihm nachstellen können, United States, Englisch, keqw, 0w, das ist meine
E-Mail Adresse, next, next, next, Passwort, okay, next, wir agreeen allem, agreege, agreet
ihr auch chat, ich hoffe wir sind uns einig, dass wir alle jetzt bei jeep agreeen, agreege
time, export, wo ist, wo ist meine E-Mail Adresse, E-Mail Adresse, die hier, wir brauchen
jetzt nicht mein Dodge Login, sondern mein jeep Login, Passwort, reply, so brand, also
fiat region amerika ist richtig, allerdings brand ist jeep, okay, schauen wir mal was
passiert, run, funktioniert, also ich kann das nicht nachvollziehen, dass es Probleme
gibt beim Login, das ist halt das dumme, bei mir funktioniert's, region amerika jeep,
so und er sagt er bekommt Probleme, er bekommt Probleme nach dem Login, also wenn er das hier
macht, vehicle stage all, could not be deserialized to jason, kann das sein, dass eigentlich alles
funktioniert, aber jeep irgendwelche nicht passbares jason zurückliefert, was ich jetzt
nicht ausprobieren kann, weil ich keine Autos auf meinem account habe, also sprich, das ist
natürlich jetzt doof, apurl, hier kackt das ab bei ihm, could not deserialize, jeep wird
mit irgendwas antworten, was ist, was ist nicht, also was vehicle response, wie sieht
das aus, user id, version, ja irgendwas hier wird da nicht serialisieren können, okay,
da bleibt uns jetzt nichts anderes übrig, das können wir nicht so ohne weiteres fixen,
weil ich nicht weiß woran es hängt, es könnte durchaus sein, dass die irgendwas hier zurückliefern,
was hier nicht funktioniert, also was auch immer vielleicht ist, model, string oder
sowas, das müssen wir mal gucken, das heißt uns bleibt jetzt eigentlich nichts anderes
übrig, außer hier ein bisschen mehr zu loggen oder, was soll man sonst machen, also wir
können die exception nochmal ausgeben, wobei die message haben wir ja schon, attp exception,
die message können wir ausgeben und wir können eine sache probieren, den status code, wobei
da sagt ihr schon, response could not deserialize, status, wir können eigentlich nur ein bisschen
mehr debug machen, was anderes fällt mir jetzt an der stelle wirklich nicht ein, error, okay
und jetzt hier response und dann muss er das mal ausprobieren und wir müssen gucken ob
es funktioniert, was anderes fällt mir nämlich gerade echt nicht ein, so und response ist
quasi call, ne ne response ist nicht gleich status code, response ist das was man im body
drinne hat, body, ne, request body, funktioniert das jetzt, content oder ne, wie geht das,
wie geht das, wollte ich nach request gucken, ne request body, available only if attp request
message content is a floral content, was ich denn, ich will auch nicht request ich will
only response, response message, content, ne, read, warte mal wie ging das denn jetzt nochmal,
jetzt ersetzt attp response message, is success status message, what, read as string, alter
können wir es noch komplizierter machen bitteschön, response, attp response message, content,
okay ich seh schon das geht nicht anscheinend, wir haben response, ach hier, hier get string
async, das wollen wir haben, ja, so die sache ist jetzt die, das geht doch bestimmt kaputt,
wir müssen checken ob das null ist, wir müssen checken ob das null ist, ne ne das nicht,
das ist, das ist nicht null, das hier müssen wir gucken ob es null ist, was soll der jetzt
verschmerzen, das gucken ob es null ist und wir müssen gucken ob response vielleicht
null ist, okay, so mehr als so ein bisschen debug message können wir wahrscheinlich gar
nicht da jetzt, gar nicht tun, ne, also wir können aber mal, wir können aber mal versuchen
zu testen ob, ob wir das nachstellen, also nicht nachstellen ob wir den Fehler, ob wir
das testen können, dass zumindest die Error Ausgabe halbwegs, halbwegs sinnvoll ist und
zwar wir faken das einfach mal, wir gehen jetzt mal hier in fiat client und hier braucht
er ja den, ne, warte mal, wo sind wir, da fetch, hier braucht er ja api key, das benutzt er
da auch schon, ich will dass der, ich will dass der fehl schlägt, okay wir gehen jetzt
einfach nicht auf v4 accounts vehicles sondern auf vehicles und guck mal was passiert, weil
das sollte ja auf jeden fall nicht funktionieren oder api key plus abc, ja das stimmt schon,
error connecting to vehicles not found, okay das ist jetzt ein anderes problem, ja wir
machen wirklich, das ist eine gute Idee chat, high iq chat, error connecting to, ähm,
aber es geht, jetzt haben wir das Bild
Das ist ein anderer Fehler, den wir jetzt kriegen.
Response could not be deserialized to JSON.
Okay, das können wir auch nachstellen.
Das können wir auch nachstellen.
Wir schreiben hier einfach irgendeinen Mist rein.
Was weiß ich hier, das soll ein Bool sein, User ID.
So, und dann sollte es zumindest an der Stelle doch auch abkacken.
Auf, kack ab, please.
Ah, ich hab kein Debugging an, deswegen ging das jetzt grad nicht.
Ich sag doch hier Debug, das ist ja Blödsinn.
Ich hab ja gar kein Debugging an und ich will auch gar kein Debugging zum Testen anhaben,
weil dann seht ihr mein Passwort und sowas.
Okay, mach mal einfach Info, sollte jetzt genauso funktionieren.
Hier, alles klar, oh, das ist falsch.
Response could not be deserialized to JSON, blabla.
Okay, das bestärkt mich in der Annahme, dass die irgendeinen Mist responden, den es gar
nicht gibt oder geben sollte.
Ich hab irgendwas nicht erwartet, kann das sein?
Kann man, meine blöde Frau hat gesagt, kann man null überhaupt erwarten?
Nee, oder?
Nee, nee, nee, also ich muss jetzt quasi erstmal checken, okay, okay, okay, das ist ja eklig.
Kann ich, ich mein, ich könnte, ich könnte es halt einfach sagen, das geht wahrscheinlich.
Okay, das ist, das ist im Prinzip das, was wir haben wollen, ja, das soll so sein, also
der sagt den Error, den Status Code und die Response, ist schön, das können wir so lassen.
Nice, wie sieht es eigentlich aus jetzt mit, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Okay, dann geht es heute nicht weiter, ich hab keinen Bock auf den Motor von Scheiß.
Leute, wir sehen uns im nächsten Stream, bis dann, see you!